Tony Fair has told Sky News that Theresa
Mays brexit deal won't get the support
of MPs and urged her to change course Mr
Blair said some of the people in her
coalition were unreasonable and the
former prime minister admitted he felt
very sympathetic to the situation she's
found herself in he's missing too our
deputy political editor Beth Rigby who
began by asking whether a second
referendum would further divide the
country I think we've had 30 months of
negotiation there is no real consensus
is what former breaks are people won and
the deal that the Prime Minister's
finally concluded with Europe is a deal
that no one really wants so I think the
logical thing is to go back to the
people and say you're gonna have to give
us direction because Parliament can't
agree on what form it breaks it and it's
clear that as a result of this
negotiation our knowledge of what breaks
it really means has been vastly enlarged
I think the odd thing with the decision
of this magnitude is not once you go
through the process of negotiation to go
back at the end and have a final think
about it you said in your speech and the
Q&A after that getting through the
brexit impasse would take real
leadership Mrs May doesn't have it house
does she she doesn't got what it takes
what she could do I mean if she if you
wanted to lead right now she would
realize that her deals not gonna get
through she needs to construct a process
in Parliament where you go through the
options I mean there are any number of
different Briggs adoptions I mean three
principally really that's a Briggs if
that's softer than her brexit which is
the sort of what people call the Norway
option that's a brexit that's harder
than than her deal which is the
so-called Canada option or there's her
deal okay if Parliament votes on all of
those three and there's not a majority
in parliament for any of them it's got
to decide whether they'd have a
referendum and you you also said that
you knew as a Prime Minister former
prime minister yourself you knew that
she wouldn't get any further concessions
at the European Council this week did
she lie to her in peace to save her job
no I don't think so I think I think she
she told them what she wanted
but I can't believe that she could ever
thought she would get it because the
whole point about this Irish backstop is
that originally it was Britain that said
we've got to have a frictionless border
between north and south of Ireland the
truth is the only way of maintaining a
frictionless border for trading purposes
is if you remain part of the trading
system of Europe she was trying to save
her skin yeah but you know there's a
better way of saving it well
she survived a confidence vote now she's
in office for another year so I think
she would take that off as a win
wouldn't she yeah maybe she would but
she still got the big problem how she
gets breaks it through and and that's
why I say the only the sensible thing
for her to do is to realize there are
divisions in our cabinet never mind her
government never mind Parliament so what
what can she do as Prime Minister what
she can do is facilitate a decision do
you feel sorry for her I feel very
sympathetic to the stress and strain of
the job to the difficulty she finds
herself in I mean frankly she has got
some very unreasonable people in her own
party and in her coalition but they you
know in the end I am sympathetic to him
but she's got to realize now she's got
to switch course because if she just
carries on in the same vein she's not
going to succeed but there's no point in
her thinking she's just gonna batter the
MPs he says keep driving at the brick
wall and saying guys here's the brick
wall and we're gonna crash out with no
deal because the parliament in the end
will take the steering wheel offer and
avoid the brick wall so that's why she
would be better to steer off the brick
wall herself just finally 80 percent 90
percent 100 sort of how likely is a
second referendum in your view I think
it's gone over 50 percent for the first
time I mean I don't sense a bit
arbitrary but but I think when you
analyze it it's the old Sherlock Holmes
thing when you exclude the impossible
what whatever remains however improbable
is the answer and I don't think it's
possible to get any of these other
options through Parliament if you were
Jeremy Coreper and you're thinking I
don't need about this people's vote we
are going to have a general election
shortly
I can't see it any Tory MPs voting for a
general election I mean the one thing
that would most imperil the Tories in
government is to fight a general
election with Briggs if there's an issue
because then you have people who would
vote labour because they don't like the
conservative position on brexit whereas
you know frankly if you took Briggs it
out of the equation then you were
fighting on what I would call normal
politics you know the economy law and
order and so on health service you know
you if I was a Tory I I'd feel a lot
more confident about fighting that
election than I would if you had a
general election with Briggs it as a
dominant issue this would be nuts for
the Tory party to do it